do you have advice
for uh young people in high school and
college maybe um
if they're interested in ai or
interested in having a
big impact on the world what they should
do to have a career they can be proud of
her to have a life they can be proud of
i love giving talks to the next
generation what i say to them is
actually two things i i think the most
important things to learn about
and to find out about when you're when
you're young is what are your true
passions is first of all there's two
things one is find your true passions
and i think you can do that by the way
to do that is to explore as many things
as possible when you're young and you
you have the time and you and you can
take those risks i would also encourage
people to look at the finding the
connections between things uh in a
unique way i think that's a really great
way to find a passion second thing i
would say advise is know yourself so
spend a lot of time understanding how
you work best like what are the optimal
times to work what are the optimal ways
that you study um what are your how do
you deal with pressure um sort of test
yourself in various scenarios and try
and improve your weaknesses um but also
find out what your unique skills and
strengths are and then hone those so
then that's what you will be your super
value in the world later on and if you
can then combine those two things and
find passions that you're genuinely
excited about that intersect with what
your unique strong skills are then
you're you know you're on to something
incredible and and you know i think you
can make a huge difference in the world
so let me ask about know yourself this
is fun this is fun quick questions about
day in the life the perfect day the
perfect productive day in the life of
demise's house yeah maybe uh maybe these
days you're um
there's a lot involved yeah it may be a
slightly younger temperature
demonstration where you could focus on a
single project maybe um
how early do you wake up are you night
owl do you wake up early in the morning
what are some interesting habits
uh how many dozens of cups of coffees do
you drink a day what's the computer um
that you use
uh what's the setup how many screens
what kind of keyboard are we talking uh
emacs vim are we talking something more
modern so it's a bunch of those
questions so maybe a day in the life
what what's the perfect day involved
well these days it's quite different
from say 10 20 years ago back 10 20
years ago it would have been you know a
whole day of
research individual research or
programming doing some experiment
neuroscience computer science experiment
reading lots of research papers uh and
then perhaps at night time you know
reading science fiction books or or
playing uh some games but lots of focus
so like deep focused work on whether
it's uh
programming or reading research paper
yes yes so that would be a lot of
debrief you know uh focus work these
days for the last sort of i guess you
know five to ten years i've actually got
quite a structure that works very well
for me now which is that um i'm a night
complete night out always have been so i
optimized for that so you know i get you
know i basically do a normal day's work
get into work about 11 o'clock and sort
of do work to about seven uh in the
office uh and i will arrange
back-to-back meetings for the entire
time of that and with as many me as many
people as possible so that's my
collaboration management part of the day
then i go home
spend time with the family and friends
uh have dinner uh uh relax a little bit
and then i start a second day of work i
call it my second day of work around 10
pm 11 pm and that's the time till about
the small hours of the morning four five
in the morning where i will do my
thinking and reading research writing
research papers um sadly i don't have
time to code anymore but it's it's not
efficient to to do that
these days uh given the amount of time i
have um but that's when i do you know
maybe do the long kind of stretches of
of thinking and planning and then
probably you know using using email or
other things i would set i would fire
off a lot of things to my team to deal
with the next morning for actually
thinking about this overnight we should
go for this project or arrange this
meeting the next day when you're
thinking through a problem are you
talking about a sheet of paper or the
patent pen is there some it depends
structure yeah i like processes i still
like pencil and paper best for working
out things but um these days it's just
so efficient to read research papers
just on the screen i still often print
them out actually i still prefer to
mark out things and i find it goes into
the brain quick um better and sticks in
the brain better when you're you're
still using physical pen and pencil and
paper so you take notes with the i have
lots of notes electronic ones and also
um whole stacks of notebooks that that
um that i use at home yeah on some of
these most challenging next steps for
example stuff
none of us know about that you're
working on you're thinking
there's some deep thinking required
there right like what what is the right
problem what is the right approach
because you're gonna have to invest a
huge amount of time for the whole team
they're going to have to pursue this
thing what's the right way to do it is
is rl gonna work here yes um
what's the right thing to try what's the
right benchmark to use yeah we need to
construct a benchmark from scratch all
those kinds of things yes so i think all
those kind of things in the night time
phase but also much more um i find i've
always found the quiet hours of the
morning um when everyone's asleep it's
super quiet outside um i love that time
it's the golden hours like between like
one and three in the morning um put some
music on some spyro music on and then um
think these deep thoughts so that's when
i would read you know my philosophy
books and uh spinoza's my you know
recent favorite can all these things i i
i you know read about a great uh uh
a scientist of history how they did
things how they thought things so that's
when you do all your create that's when
i do all my creative thinking and it's
good i think i think people recommend
you know you do your your your sort of
creative thinking in one block and the
way i organize the day that way i don't
get interrupted because obviously no one
else is up uh at those times so i can i
can go uh you know as i can sort of get
super deep and super into flow the other
nice thing about doing it night time
wise is if i'm really uh onto something
or if i've got really deep into
something i can choose to extend it and
i'll go into six in the morning whatever
and then i'll just pay for it the next
day yeah cause i'll be a bit tired and i
won't be my best but that's fine i can
decide looking at my schedule the next
day
and given where i'm at with this
particular thought or creative idea that
i'm gonna pay that cost the next day so
so i think that's that's more flexible
than morning people who do that you know
they get up at four in the morning they
can also do those golden hours then but
then their start of their schedule day
starts at breakfast you know 8 a.m
whatever they have their first meeting
and then it's hard you have to
reschedule a day if you're in flow yeah
that could be i don't have to do that
special threat of thoughts that
you're too passionate about you that
this is where some of the greatest ideas
could potentially come is when you just
lose yourself
later
and for the meetings i mean you're
loading in really hard problems in a
very short amount of time so you have to
do some kind of first principles
thinking here it's like what's the
problem what's the state of things
what's the right next step yes you have
to get really good at context switching
which is one of the hardest things
because especially as we do so many
things if you include all the scientific
things we do scientific fields we're
working in these are entire you know
complex fields in themselves and you you
have to sort of keep up to abreast of
that but i enjoy it i've always been uh
a sort of generalist in a way and that's
actually what happened with my game's
career after chess i i i one of the
reasons i stopped playing chess was that
i got into computers but also i started
realizing there were many other great
games out there to play too so i've
always been that way inclined
multi-disciplinary and there's too many
interesting things in in the world to
spend all your time just on one thing
you